(upbeat music)
- Hey Drew, this is Sergeant Griswold,
stationed at Fort Sill, Oklahoma.
- Hi Drew, I'm PFC Khalan Moore,
I'm stationed at Fort Bliss, Texas.
- I'd like to give a shout
out to my wife and son.
I love you guys, and I
can't wait to be home.
- I'd like to send a shout out
to my mom Dalia in Houston, Texas.
Hi mom, I hope you're having
a great day, I love you.
- Hey Drew, this is
Sergeant Matthew Samelak,
stationed out of Fort Sill, Oklahoma.
- Hi Drew, my name is
Master Sergeant Maddox,
I'm stationed at Fort Hood, Texas.
- Hi Drew, my name is
Specialist Omar Gomez,
currently stationed overseas.
- I'd love to give a shout out to my mom.
I don't get to see her very often,
but I sorely miss her home cooking.
Love you, mom, can't wait to see you soon.
- 'Cause I wanna give a quick shout out
to my family back at
home, I love you guys.
- Just wanna give a shout
out to my wife, Jenny,
my parents, Eric and
Sue, my sister, Megan.
I hope you guys have a great holidays.
I miss you guys and love you
guys, and I'll be home soon.
(upbeat music)